that's when you win it at the point
where they stop fighting you and start
pretending to be like you hi I'm Nicolas
be with reason TV and today we're
talking with Matt kibbe he's the head of
Freedom Works and he's the author most
recently of the great new book don't
hurt people and don't take their stuff a
libertarian manifesto Matt thanks for
talking to pay Nick how's it going okay
don't hurt people and don't take their
stuff and then you've got a whole book
after that what what needs to be
expanded on you know I think I wanted to
translate basic libertarian Valley
values into plain English and and people
would always ask me what should I read
if I want to understand what
libertarians stand for and you'd say
something like go read Adam Smith's
Theory of Moral Sentiments which is
another way of giving them the anger
it's another way of bothering don't even
think about considering libertarianism
so I just wanted to translate it into
into basic values and get them to
understand that that what we talk about
when we talk about freedom is really
just common sense right and well and you
talk about it I mean obviously titular
Lee it's don't hurt people and don't
take their stuff you also talk about
taking personal responsibility that
Liberty demands that you are responsible
things like that what you also talk
about the non-aggression principle is
very basic to your worldview explain
that a little bit yeah I mean it the
whole basis of peaceful cooperation is
is not hurting people not violating
their rights their most basic right to
life and you know libertarians a little
bit different cuz they don't they don't
want to start a fight with anybody they
want to be left alone when you apply
that to foreign policy I'm kind of a
Washingtonian it's it's it's practical
and by that you mean a George Washington
II and not a Beltway yeah yeah George
Washington and he basically said let's
avoid entangling alliances it was a
pragmatic position for him it's like do
we have money to nation-build can we
actually get involved in all this stuff
well in in the circles you travel in
Freedom Works which you know promotes
candidates and causes and issues around
the country you know moving towards a
more libertarian free minds free-market
type of thing there seems there's you
know there's a lot of fellow travel
with conservatives who seem oftentimes
to be well you know what libertarianism
or limited government stops at the
water's edge and are you finding that's
changing are conservatives more broadly
speaking you know finally starting to
question a kind of emphasis on overseas
nation-building yeah I think that's a
return to where conservatism came from I
always thought that libertarianism
conservatism were always kind of mashed
up and there was a skepticism about
about about foreign aggression and
you're seeing it in Justin Amash and and
Rand Paul and and the trend from the
Republican classes in 2010 and 2012 are
they principled about that or are they
situational doves kind of we're you know
okay because you know Democrats who
didn't have a problem with Barack Obama
talking about bombing Syria are actually
bombing Libya yeah you know they were
against the Iraq war after they voted
for it and things like that are the
Republicans going to become hawkish
again if and when they take the Senate
in the White House well I think it's
both I think it's easier to oppose a
Democratic president when he's proposing
to bomb Syria but I think it's a serious
philosophical shift as well and you're
going to see more and more Republicans
challenge a Republican president if if
he or she starts trampling our civil
liberties if he or she starts proposing
this kind of blank check and
nation-building you were critical
obviously of the George Bush
administration and the Republican
Congress under George Bush also critical
of Democrats are we getting to a point
where back to back you have a kind of
nightmare scenario of conservative
Republican government doing everything
they say they're against you know they
blew out the budget they expanded
entitlements they made war overseas
after promising a humble foreign policy
with Obama you have a guy who came in
saying I'm not I'm gonna close Gitmo we
kept it open I'm gonna get us out of
dumb war is he tripled troop strength in
Afghanistan he's terrible on civil
liberties is this like the set setting
the table for a great libertarian
reaction to just say look we've tried it
on the right we've tried it on the left
now let's try it libertarian style I do
think that is the trend and I think a
lot of the reason you're seeing so many
people
interested in libertarian ideas is a
failure the Republicans the failures of
Democrats but also the ability to go get
the information for yourself you're not
you're not waiting for the RNC to tell
you what to think anymore and you know I
tell a story in the book about Justin
Amash
trying to figure out why he didn't quite
fit in with Republicans he just typed it
into Google right up pops FA Hyack I
think more and more young people are
building their own curriculums and kid
didn't get it in high school didn't get
it in college but all of a sudden all
the things that I struggled to find when
I was a teenager you can find with just
at your keyboard I talked about how that
plays out in political organizing
because that's you know one of the
things you do you're kind of a community
organizer a political organizer you have
some fun with that in the book given
that those are often words described you
know used to describe a Barack Obama but
you know how does the Internet and the
decentralization of knowledge help
change political battles you know it
lowers barriers to entry for citizens
that want to know what their government
is doing it makes it easier for people
to connect with each other without a
middleman through social media and if
you think about it in public choice
terms what what do the power mongers do
they monopolize information and if that
wall comes down and the shareholders and
the voters know what's going on in
Washington I think it's a fundamental
shift in the balance of power in our
favor and you're seeing that with the
emergence of the Tea Party with the
emergence of the Ron Paul revolution all
of these trends towards democratization
and decentralization make me more
optimistic about the future of actually
reigning in Washington and and getting a
seat at the table for libertarian ideas
let me push back on that a little bit I
mean I love to hear that that's music to
my years but you know we are now in a
position where president has released
his budget plan for the next ten years
and in ten years out he wants to be
spending five point nine trillion
dollars the Republicans came out with
their program they want to spend four
point nine trillion dollars in ten years
you know what are we winning here or are
we just kind of deluding ourselves and
you know on internet chat groups or
you're you're you have this clash and
and there's a lot of people in
Washington John Boehner and
Mitch McConnell being two on the
Republican side that are essentially
protecting the status quo further there
from the old system and they think that
that cutting spending is bad politics
they have a lot of crony interests
including defense interests that want to
see more and more spending and then you
have this this new class that that's
pushing against them we haven't reached
that tipping point yet and that's the
Amash is the Thomas Massey's the Rand
Paul's the Mike Lee's and there's in a
historic if you look at it historically
there's a lot more fiscal Hawks smaller
libertarians in Congress I think in the
history of America but we haven't
reached that tipping point yet but the
clash that that's civil war within the
GOP it tells me that we must be knocking
on the front door right now because
they're getting really hostile about it
how much how much of this shift within
the Republican Party is generational I
mean all of the Tea Party guys for the
most part are you know 50 or younger and
is there any wash over into the
Democrats as well because obviously you
know great systemic change is not going
to come from one party it's got to be a
consensus you know what broad consensus
yeah you know the the problem with the
Democrats today is that the radical
progressives did a very good job of
taking over the Democratic Party and I
think I think the biggest window for for
libertarians is not to create a third
party but to actually take over the
Republican Party and that's your
previous book hostile takeover but who
are the democratical progressives who
took over the Democratic Party who are
they and are they the younger ones as
well I think it was bottom-up it was it
was this same decentralization you know
Barack Obama would be one of them he was
not the party's choice in 2008 Nancy
Pelosi became Speaker but the
progressive caucus in the house used to
be a handful of people guys like Bernie
Sanders it's not the same anymore but it
came from the outside in it wasn't an
inside job well you in one of your
chapters you quote the old whose song
won't get fooled again and it's same as
the old bus and you have a line in there
where you say to young people are being
a young person it sucks to be young
today how does that kind of
you know echo the larger themes of the
books and and the looking towards the
future of reining in spending well I'm
talking about generational theft and the
way that we're spending so much money we
don't have that's gonna that's gonna get
dumped in their lap specifically about
Obama care which which is the most
obscene reverse Robin Hood we're making
forcing young healthy less wealthy
people to cross subsidize big insurance
companies and older wealthier people I
mean that's that sucks right and it
sucks to be young because that's on top
of all this other generational that
Medicare existing Medicare Social
Security all of the unfunded liabilities
that that won't be there when they get
older and on top of that they're still
living with their parents they probably
got 50 grand and KY as a parent I see
that more as a cost on the parent not on
the child but yes and you know Nancy
Pelosi today of course celebrates
joblessness is some form of liberation
and I think kids if you don't get a job
right out of the gate it affects your
career it affects your life and and this
is the opportunity the American Dream
was always doing better I'm not sure
that's true for young people today
what um you know what what are the
things that the government should be
doing say to you know kind of perk up
the economy or get out of the way of an
economy you know and what are what are
the specific spending cuts what are the
broad numbers that we have to start
cutting in your estimation you know I
think I think there's no beautiful way
to redesign the federal budget I think
you put everything on the table and I
think I think people that leave defense
off or making a big mistake because it's
not credible entitlements nowhere is it
necessary right I mean you know defense
spending in the 21st century is more
than you know it's gone up 75 percent in
real terms
we're not fighting two wars anymore I
mean if anything should be cut it would
seem like that's a no-brainer yes and
any federal bureaucracy even if it's an
essential function of government and I
think any federal bureaucracy is better
off in a budget constrained environment
because it forces them to make choices
just like everybody else you know Rand
Paul Mike Lee Pat Toomey there's
all sorts of plans to balance the budget
we actually crowdsource the tea party
debt Commission that put everything on
the table entitlements are tougher but I
think I think the mantra there should be
choice don't don't just cram down on a
system that takes from young people and
gives them less and less overtime why
not let them save for themselves I would
get the unfunded liabilities off the
books you talk in the book particularly
about young people that you had Freedom
Works you guys did a poll where you
asked young people would you you know
like things the way they are would you
like a government that spends less and
does less and you found you know and you
can always question the wording of this
but you found broad consensus that
people are willing to say yeah give me
less but tax me less yeah and I think I
think that's true and I think young
people are naturally there's sort of a
genetically libertarian when you're
young because you you like challenging
Authority you like controlling yourself
the problem they have today is finding
that product in the political
marketplace we know the Democrats are
for they like top-down it's not at all
clear what the Republicans are for and I
think that's an opportunity for a party
or a candidate to step in and say hey
check out freedom talk a little bit then
about the midterms coming up as well as
you know let's crystal ball a bit about
2016 who were the candidates who excite
you what are the causes or the movements
beyond the Tea Party more specifically
what are the issues that you see as
going in a libertarian way or where
there's a strong case for a kind of
libertarian limited government
perspective well you know of course Rand
Paul just got a standing ovation at
Berkeley for talking about civil
liberties and reining in the NSA we've
actually joined Rand and is in his loss
is class-action lawsuit I think that's a
key issue I think civil liberties are a
big thing and a great one of those
teachable moments where you see what
abusive unfettered government power is
all about that connects with young
people perhaps more than you know let's
lower marginal tax rates and Rand Paul's
been talking about that the field in
2016
to a person is far more compelling than
the Republican field in 2012 and
obviously Rand Paul's making some
headway I think that's pretty
interesting he's developing some real
communication skills but even go down
that list everybody Ted Cruz Scott
Walker Marco Rubio go down that list and
they sound more like us than virtually
anybody in the twenty twelve field where
does a talk about immigration because
this is another you know and thinking as
you you mentioned those people in Rand
Paul just recently I said you know we
got to get past being the Republicans
have to get past being the party of
deportation which is causing a
hullabaloo on the right because they're
like oh that's an amnesty or that's this
you know what is what's the preferred
path that you lay out for immigration
reform you know I've actually talked to
some of the people I'm most respect in
Congress about writing our immigration
bill I think the principle is quite
simple if you want to come to this
country and work we want you I think the
the honest disagreement is whether or
not you should arbitrarily change the
rules once people broke them because
they couldn't get in to a rational legal
process Marco Rubio made a huge mistake
by letting a Chuck Schumer and Dick
Durbin write his bill as if the Union
Democrats wanted to legalize work right
they don't but how in a from a
libertarian perspective I mean you it's
it's hard to say okay well something
like a verify where it essentially
forces all of us to have work permits
whether you're born here whether you're
here legally or illegally that seems
like a bad idea Adam Smith you know it
was not a fan of militarized borders you
know you know you know is is it does it
I mean doesn't any kind of immigration
reform ultimately have to say you know
what the people who are here whether
they're legal or not we have to we have
to say yes and I mean the you know what
is the harm of having lots of people in
the country who weren't born here yeah I
don't think there's any harm and I think
I think the the nature of our country
embraces that but I think from a
practical point of view how would you
actually get from where we are today to
where we need to be it would be better
to look prospectively and rationalize
the process by which good people come
here to work this anything that's
Omnibus anymore it contains so much
garbage and I I don't I don't support
that the bill that the Senate passed and
I'm not I'm not an open borders guy
because I just don't I don't think that
means anything in the context of how the
world actually works talk a look well
you know what one of the curious things
the book is is a great read I mean it's
really I don't want to say well written
that sense patronize I mean it's a
totally engaging read early on you talk
about what you learned from Saul Alinsky
and of course you know over the past
decade or so Saul Alinsky has emerged
from relative anonymity to one of the
great bet Noir is of the broadly
construed right you know he's the
ultimate community organizer he wrote
rules for radicals Glenn Beck made a
kind of a career launch by attacking
Saul Alinsky and saying that he's has
thoroughly infiltrated the Democratic
Party what did you learn from Saul
Alinsky you know when when we were
forming Freedom Works we were actually
reading all of the leftist literature
and we actually read Saul Alinsky before
it was cool and and I was comparing the
rules for radicals to the rules for
Liberty and I realized how situational
and how manipulative elinsky is it was
never based on principle you read his
book it's actually dedicated to Lucifer
Google at some time and watch his fans
try to rationalize that one but I think
his point is this is all about
manipulating people into doing something
they don't want to do rules for liberty
on the other hand are clear they're
transparent they're equally applied
across the board they're simple and
that's why I think we could win if we
embraced those basic rules where you
know what is the next step forward in
terms of turning I mean because you're
very much working within the republican
party apparatus whether it's a hostile
you know and it will be a hostile
takeover but when will you know that you
a you know what kind of governing
majority I think we we know when the
community the people that actually
organize and and understand the ideas of
Liberty is big enough to matter so much
that we don't have the fight the fights
over and all of a sudden you're debating
about whether or not you know Greg
Brannon or Justin Amash should be the
next presidential candidate that's when
you win it's it at the point where they
stop fighting you and start pretending
to be like you
all right well we'll leave it there
thank you Matt kibbe that's the head of
Freedom Works and also author most
recently have don't hurt people and
don't take their stuff a libertarian
manifesto thanks for talking to thank
you for reason TV I'm Nicolas
you